تحول الى فرح زمن شوقي الموجوده في مقر
افاد
التركيه في العاصمه انقر فرح زمان اخر
تقييم للاضرار وماذا عن تلك الهزه الارضيه
التي سجلت فجرا وسط تركيا بقوه خمس درجات
وسته اعشار الدرجه على مقياس
هذه الهزه لم تكن هي الوحيده وتم وصفها من
قبل اداره الطوارئ والكوارث بالزلزال وهو
ثاني زلزال
يقع خلال الليله الماضيه فقط الى جانب
اكثر من 200 هزه ارتداديه بالنسبه الى
تبعاتها فهي تؤثر بطبيعه الحال على
الابنيه التي تصدعت اساسا بسبب الزلزال
الذي وقع فجر يوم امس بشده سبعه.7 درجات
بالنسبه لاخر التحديثات مريم نائب الرئيس
التركي فؤاد اوبتاي من المفترض ان يعقد
مؤتمرا صحفيا في هذه الغرفه في اداره
الطوارئ والكوارث في انقره ليقدم اخر
التحديثات الى الان الارقام لم تتغير
كثيرا واود ان اشير كذلك الى
وصول المساعدات الروسيه الى مطار اضنه
هبطت ثلاث طائرات تابعه لوزاره الطوارئ
الروسيه في مطار اضنه وعليها
اكثر من 100 فرد سيساهمون في عمليات
الانقاذ في عمليات الاسعاف الى جانب وحدات
تحمل معدات خاصه والى جانب بعض المساعدات
قبل ذلك كانت قد وصلت مساعدات قادمه من
اذربيجان ومن دول ثانيه
وتستعد تركيا لتلقي المزيد من المساعدات
عبر جسور جويه قدمتها بعض الدول كذلك
بالنسبه
للطرق بين الحين والاخر يتم الاعلان عن
اغلاق طرق فتح طرق بديله تحديدا تلك التي
تصل مناطق كثيره بمنطقه غازي عنتاب وهي
واحده من اكثر المناطق المتضرره اثرى هذا
الزلزال ولكن
يحاولون ايجاد طرق بديله نتحدث من طرق
بريه
مغلقه وذلك بسبب تخصيصها
لطواقم الانقاذ بالدرجه الاولى وذلك لان
عدد كبير من المدنيين الذين يريدون مغادره
تلك المناطق الى جانب عدد كبير ايضا من
المدنيين الذين يحاولون ايصال المساعدات
الى تلك المناطق يتسبب بازدحام الطرق وهو
ما قد يؤدي الى تعطيل او الى تاخير بعض
عمليات الانقاذ لذلك
يتبع المعنيون هنا طرقا من قبيل اغلاق بعض
هذه الطرق
افاد او مؤسسه اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه اعلنت ايضا عن ارتفاع اعداد
الموقفين المتواجدين الان في تلك المناطق
المنكوبه العدد بات يقارب 14,000 شخص
يساهمنا في عمليات الانقاذ من بينهم عسك
من خصصتهم وزاره الدفاع ونقلتهم عبر
الجسر الجوي والممرات الجويه التي خصصتها
عدد العسكريين تقريبا يقارب الخمسه الاف
ولكن هنالك اشخاص مدنيين ياتون من مدن
ثانيه الى جانب من توفرهم المنظمات
المعنيه منظمات حكوميه او غير حكوميه الى
جانب الهلال الاحمر التركي اسطنبول تعلن
ارسال 73 طائره الى المناطق المنكوبه
محمله بالمساعدات
بالمتطوعين ايضا نقل المصابين مستمر من
تلك المناطق اداره الكوارث كذلك تعلن عن
تخصيص سفن لنقل المصابين بحرا تحديدا من
هاتاي الى مرسين قد يكون هذا الطريق اسهل
من الطرق البريه التي يتم اغلاقها بين
الحين والاخر او التي تتعرض
للصخور بسبب تبعات الهزات الاعتداديه لكن
ايضا نقل بحرا ليس بتلك السهوله الا ان
كانت السفن ضخمه او تتبع للقوات المسلحه
وتكون قادره على نقل المصابين سريعا في ظل
ايضا وهل الجويه سيئه مريم امان الحصول او
الوصول الى ناجين احياء تحت الانقاض
شاهدنا اكثر من حاله في ديار بكر فيها تاي
وهناك ربما الجهود مستمره للوصول الى من
علقوا داخل الانقاض ويطلقون نداءات
استغاثه للوصول اليهم اداره الكوارث هل
تتحدث عن
وقت معين وقت زمني معين يمكن خلاله الوصول
الى احياء والى اي مدى ما زالت الامال
قائمه للوصول الى المزيد منهم وفق المتاح
من وسائل
قائمه هي في الحقيقه لاسيما مع توالي
الانباء التي ما زالت تاتي من تلك المناطق
باخراج احياء وليس فقط باخراج وفيات لكن
الجميع يعلم بانه كلما مر الوقت اكثر كلما
تضاءلت هذه الفرص ليس فقط بسبب بقائهم تحت
الانقاذ هنا ايضا اصابات قد تكون اصابات
بالغه قد تتضاعف بقائهم من غير
من دون طعام من دون شراب لذلك خلال تجارب
سابقه لتركيا في زلازل من هذا القبيل لحال
وجود عالقين لا يمكن اخراجهم بسهوله يجب
ايضا تامين طرق لايصال
الدواء او او الطعام او الشراب لهؤلاء
العالقين تحت الانقاذ ان كان ذلك متاحا
الامور هنالك بحسب اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
وبحسب ما اكد وزير الصحه في مؤتمر الصحفيه
عقده يوم امس من منطقتها
المنكوبه يؤكد بان الامور صعبه وبانهم
يواجهون صعوبه في اخراج العالقين من تحت
الانقاذ مريم السبب ان الابنيه التي
انهارت في تلك المدن هي ابنيه كبيره طويله
فيها عدد كبير من المباني بعضها ابنيه
حديثه فهنالك ابنيه تتكون من عشر الطوابق
او 12 طابقا عدد كبير من البيوت هنالك
عائلات باكملها عالقه تحت الانقاض لذلك
نحن نتحدث عن توا متعدده لا نتحدث فقط عن
قرى او عن بيوت
بسيطه تتكون من طابق واحد نتحدث ايضا عن
عشره مدن عشره مدن الدمار فيها هائل تصفها
اداره الكوارث هنا بانها مدن منكوبه ومدن
متضرره لذلك عمليات الانقاذ لا تسير
بثلاثه في الحقيقه رغم توفر المعدات ورغم
وصول المساعدات سواء المساعدات القادمه من
مدن ثانيه او المساعدات التي تاتي من دول
اخرى لكن اولا هنالك صعوبه في الوصول الى
تلك المناطق لذلك تحول السلطات الان تامين
ممرات سواء عبر تخصيص طرق واغلاقها امام
عربات المدنيين او عبر الجسور الجويه او
حتى عبر البحر المساله كذلك هي في كيفيه
استخدام الاليات الثقيله العمليات تبقى
حساسه بطبيعه الحال اداره الكوارث يوم امس
تتحدث عن
وجود انهيارات حصلت في غازي عنتاب وفي
اضنه خلال عمليات البحث وذلك لان استخدام
الاليات والرافعات الثقيله من الممكن ايضا
ان يؤذي الاحياء ان كانوا احياء موجودين
وعالقين تحت الانقاض مريم لذلك هي بالفعل
عمليه حساسه وهذه الحساسيه قد تؤدي الى
تباطؤ عمليات الانقاذ في الساعات المقبله
منعا او تجنبا لحصول اي انهيارات قد تهدد
حياه العالقين تحت الانقاذ
ان كانوا مصابين وان لم يكونوا في عداد
الوفيات فراح زمان شوقي شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
الان نع